Eddie and I uh our buddies going back to
when we were 18 19 years old
and so Eddie uh we this is before the
internet Eddie heard about this young
black comic in LA and I heard about this
young black comic in New York but that
was it and we heard about it because of
the the comics and the the doorman and
the managers that would come from New
York to LA or LA to New York and they
say oh there's there's this guy
so I always heard about him and I got a
call from Jim McCauley of The Tonight
Show he was the guy who booked all the
comics on The Tonight Show right and he
said there's this guy from Saturday
Night Live
and he's coming out here uh to do The
Tonight Show and he would like to meet
you
will you are you willing to meet him and
I go what's his name he goes Eddie
Murphy I go absolutely I've heard about
Eddie for years you know we've been in
the club since we were 14. 15. I think
he came in 15 16. we've heard about each
other for three four years absolutely so
he goes he'll be at the comedy store
tonight
so I go to The Comedy Store
and Eddie's at the one end of the hall
he's down there by the ER by the the uh
the main room uh you know if you know
and I was over by the original room so
it was like at the end of the hall it
was like out of a western right
and and so he just kind of nods at me
like this like we've known each other
all our lives and I nod back and he
walks up to me he goes what's up I go
what's up what you want to do you want
to go get something he goes yeah let's
go get something it was like we had been
like raised together in the same
neighborhood all without ever me without
ever meeting it was like hey what's up
what's up you want to go get something
to eat let's go get something
so we go to my car
and I had a beige four-door Honda
and
it was not impressed
he
looks at my car he goes is this your car
I go yeah this is my car
he goes he looks at it and so and then
he goes why do you he goes do you have
kids
I go no I don't have any kids he goes
why do you have a back seat
I said what came with the car he goes he
goes I just bought a 280ZX
he goes you know what I did with the
back seat I go no he goes I took the
back seat out and it's a giant speaker
he goes so when I'm driving down the
street people hear me thumping I go oh
that's a good idea he goes yeah get rid
of your back seat put in a speaker right
okay I'll think about that so we go in a
Beijing in a beige four-door Honda
he didn't want to be seen in this car
and I don't think he's ever been seen in
a car like this before ever again so we
go to the restaurant the mustache Cafe
across from the Improv and we're sitting
there and we're talking about comedy and
talking about you know everything and
then Eddie says I said so what brings
you to La I thought it was to do the
tonight she goes not tonight he goes I'm
out here to do a fitting
for a movie
I go really because yeah he goes I play
a convict he goes but but I don't he
goes I don't wear convict clothes he
goes I wear really nice clothes he goes
I don't look like a convict he goes I
look sharp he goes I'm out here to do a
fitting he goes have you ever heard of
uh Giorgio Armani
and I go no he goes he's an Italian
designer and they're going to put me in
Giorgio Armani suits and I'm gonna look
real good he goes I play this guy to get
me out of prison for 48 hours and I go
capture a bad guy he goes so here's the
deal he said this is my first movie he
goes uh if it doesn't work we're gonna
blame the movie on my co-star some guy
named Nick noltech
he says but if the movie does work I'm
going to take all the credit
so
he goes by you know so I start talking
about how much I love TV and I love
television I want to do more television
he's like oh forget TV he goes be in the
movie business he comes the movie
business is the greatest business in the
world he goes when I landed Byron
they gave me an envelope
and in that envelope and oh by the way
he said I'm keeping the suits because
I'm not giving the suits back he goes
but in this envelope was per diem he I
go per diem he goes yeah it's cash just
to spend cash he goes 1500 bucks he goes
I opened an envelope I looked around he
goes I'm keeping this cash
and so Eddie was like straight up just
do movies right so I remember we were in
his kitchen and this is the house that
he bought from Cher Cher had this
beautiful home on Benedict Canyon and
Eddie body walked in and literally said
how much they the time many 30 years ago
what at 40. he goes
five and a half million he goes okay he
was staying in a hotel right he said
okay we're good
like he literally they had to no like no
you have to go back to the hotel you
can't stay now
he didn't want to leave right oh he
thought he just bought it like I'm good
five and a half million we're good I'm
gonna stay here now
foreign
[Music]